[Applause]
please welcome Tim Robbins Colin Farrell
be refer me gasps Julianne Moore and
Michelle Pfeiffer
[Music]
[Music]
the first day of shooting on the
Fabulous Baker boys Jeff Bridges and I
shared the same makeup artist and after
spending two hours meticulously removing
all of my flaws she turns to Jeff and
upon his direction hand paints onto his
face every broken capillary she just
removed from mine I know it sounds
trivial but it is that kind of attention
to detail and lack of vanity that has
always made Jeff not just a great actor
but a brilliant one
on that same film I watched him play
with his 3 toe head daughters in between
setups and I saw that you can have a
career and a strong marriage and a
family and managed to turn out year
after year great performances like we
saw as crazy hearts bad Blake an amazing
human being Jeff Bridges has created not
only alike we can respect and aspire to
but the performance of a lifetime
so you might think being cast as George
Clooney's love interest would be a
little intimidating and you would be
right but that only lasts until you
actually meet him with that crinkle in
his eye that mischievous smile that
warmth you just want to cozy up to he
makes you forget everything but the
scene that you're playing his only
objective is to draw from you your best
performance which he cares about more
than his own in and he lives this in the
spirit of generosity both on and off the
screen he is a humanitarian of the first
order he is an effortless and versatile
actor an intuitive director and a
fantastic reason tastic mr. foxy fox or
in the woods are my mom's coworkers he's
just so dreamy
now most most people would be happy with
just one of these accomplishments but
George you have them all congratulations
my friend
[Music]
in a single man colin firth and I play
to people who have been best friends for
20 years
in reality we had just met and only
worked together for three days I had
only heard exemplary things about him
and so had extremely high expectations
and he managed to exceed everyone with
his ease charm humour and generosity it
wasn't hard for me to believe that I'd
known and loved him all of my life his
courage and integrity and letting us see
the depth of one man's shattering grief
is testament to his enormous talent and
I can tell you that three days not
nearly enough time to spend in the
company by the Magnificent Colin Firth
morgen we became friends working
together on the Shawshank Redemption for
which you were nominated for an Academy
Award the film follows the trajectory of
a friendship and that friendship was
easily mirrored in real life on the set
I'll never forget what you said to me
about friendship on the last day of
shooting you said being a friend is
getting the other a cup of coffee can
you do that for me Ted
[Applause]
it is Ted isn't it
we became so close
honestly Morgan is an extremely giving
actor and a master at his craft and an
inspiration to all those lucky enough to
have the chance to work with him
considering the dignity and integrity
that he brings to all his work I was not
surprised to learn that he'd been
nominated tonight for his role as the
great Nelson Mandela Kitty Morgan I
salute you and your tremendous talent
and I'm always proud to call you my
friend when you take the call
I was fortunate to get to know Jeremy
during a film we did together called
SWAT and we had some good times both on
and off the set including that trip to
Mexico man which I wish I remembered
more of but I'll never forget sharing a
bed with you that one night I think we
actually shared a pillow and before any
rumors start you should know that all it
was was spooning even those SWAT was a
down the line action film two things
were obvious working with Jeremy even
then it was your raw talent man and your
kindness and your generosity to those
around you regardless of their station
it was an absolute inspiration you're
nominated performance was such a delight
for me to watch after a nearly 20 year
career to see you get the chance to do a
level film and tackle a depth of
character that complimented your ability
so we'll it just felt right they really
did Cena your work gloriously avoided
political persuasion which for me was
lovely because it wasn't left or right
it was just one man who was beautiful it
was alive it was honest and it's my
honor to say this nomination is so well
deserved brother and yeah good luck
Jerry
[Music]
please welcome last year's Academy Award
winner for Actress in a leading role
Kate Winslet
[Music]
the great thing about this award coming
near the end of the show is there's no
need for me to do anything other than to
enjoy this honor and to announce the
names of the five brilliant gentlemen
who are the nominees for Best
Performance by an actor in a leading
role Jeff Bridges in Crazy Heart George
Clooney in up in the air
colin firth in a single man
Morgan Freeman in Invictus
and jeremy renner in the heart Locker
and the Oscar goes to Jeff Bridges
[Applause]
the first Academy Award and fifth
nomination for Jeff Bridges he comes
from a show business family including
his father Lloyd mother Dorothy and
brother beau Jeff received his first
nomination in 1971 for a supporting role
in the last picture show
[Applause]
Oh
thank you Academy number
[Applause]
thank you mom and dad for turning me on
to City
groobie profession oh my dad my mom had
loved showbiz so much I remember my mom
getting all of his kids to entertain her
to parties you know my dad sitting me on
his bed and teach me all of the basics
of acting for a role in Sea Hunt they
love showbiz so much and I feel an
extension of them you know this this is
honoring Dennis as much as me I wanna I
want to thank Scott Cooper are a
wonderful director for his his knowledge
of film and country music and for his
ability to instill self confidence in
his actors I thank you for for that
Scott where are you raise your hand man
yeah Scotty thank you for that Scott man
and thank you for assembling such a
wonderful cast Maggie Gyllenhaal Colin
whether he is backstage and Bobby Duvall
so wonderful you guys brought your heart
and soul I want to thank Barry Markowitz
our wonderful DP it's such a brilliant
job Judy Cairo our producer and Fox
Searchlight are wonderful a wonderful
distributor thank you guys for keeping
us all together and and for making it
all happen t-bone Burnett
and Stephen Bruton for bringing all that
great music in those wonderful musicians
to the party man
yeah and to my my wonderful team that
that's kept me together Jean severs
David shift Rick Kurtzman and CAA
Bob wallerstein Lloyd Catlett Tara Day
and Roger love man thank you guys and I
especially want to thank my gorgeous
wife Sue we've been married 33 years we
have the beautiful family three girls
Isabel Jesse and Hailey thank you guys I
wouldn't be up here without you thank
you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]